bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce lundi 12 juillet en iran les
manifestations étudiantes se multiplient
des affrontements violents ont eu lieu à
téhéran un étudiant a été tué à tabriz
comme il ya 20 ans aux cris à bas le
despotisme
en iran la station mir pourrait être
évacuée d'urgence de lancement d'un
engin ravitaillement prévu mercredi
n'est pas assurée
l'inauguration de la 5e ligne du rer
eole 8 milliards de francs 7 ans de
travaux ont été nécessaires pour relier
la banlieue est de paris au centre de la
capitale
l'étrange histoire de monsieur alfred
âgé de 54 ans et vivant depuis 11 ans
dans l'enceinte de l'aéroport de roissy
2 vient de recevoir un statut de réfugié
politique
il y a un an l'équipe de france de
football était championne du monde et un
et deux et trois zéro face au brésil
souvenirs souvenirs et entretien
exclusif avec ronaldo la star
brésilienne qui fit tant défaut à son
équipe 12 juillet 98 ce début d'été en
iran a des allures de printemps de pékin
les manifestations étudiantes se
succèdent dans la capitale iranienne
téhéran pour réclamer des réformes
démocratiques et contester les méthodes
policières à tabriz
un étudiant a été tué dans plusieurs
villes de province les troubles
s'étendent et l'on voit même grossir
c'est le mouvement étudiant par d'autres
catégories de la population
mécontentes de leur sort commentaire
jérôme baugnies
bravant les mises en garde des services
de sécurité ils sont des milliers
d'étudiants aujourd'hui encore dans les
rues de téhéran pour la première fois
depuis la révolution islamique il ya 20
ans ils haussent criaient des slogans
hostiles aux autorités religieuses
conservatrices et à la police à
l'origine du mouvement la fermeture du
journal salam favorables au président
rabbani
les manifestants brandissent des
portraits du président iranien élu il ya
deux ans ils protestent contre les
tenants de la ligne dure qui veulent
empêcher le président de mener ces
réformes
l'enjeu est grave les heurts avec la
police
violent la contestation s'étend à de
nombreuses villes de province à tabriz
au nord-ouest
la préfecture annonce la mort d'un
étudiant en théologie tué par balles
hier sur la sellette
l'autorité suprême ali khamenei héritier
de l'imam khomeiny c'est le guide de la
république islamique chef de file des
conservateurs
il a tenu à s'adresser à ses nombreux
fidèles
il prétend vouloir calmer le jeu même si
les manifestants brûlent mon portrait ne
cédez pas à la violence dit il avec en
écho les lamentations de l'assistance
et le guide suprême de s'en prendre à
l'éternel ennemi les états unis pourtant
rien ne prouve l'implication américaine
dans ce nouvel épisode de la lutte à
téhéran autres réformateurs et
conservateurs
et coïncidence des dates il y a 20 ans
en 1979 les foules iranienne encouragé
par les religieux dénonçait le
despotisme d'un autre régime celui du
chat deux décennies plus tard la
contestation est certes moins organisés
moins structuré et ceux qui s'affrontent
à la police du régime des mollahs n'ont
pas connu autre chose que la révolution
islamique
celle ci est aujourd'hui partagée entre
conservateurs et libéraux commentaires
gérard griesbeck
le guide de la révolution l'ayatollah
khamenei ses soeurs d'euros mais géra
griesbeck a expliqué ce qui c'est ce qui
est en train de se passer au sein du
régime iranien c'est à dire cette
séparation entre ceux qui soutiennent
celui qui est le guide de la révolution
khamenei qui se tuent par les
conservateurs et puis les libéraux du
président la république khatami c'est
celui-ci qui pour l'instant soutenu par
les étudiants qui font donc pour
l'instant une série de manifestations
ils réclament des réformes des réformes
de plus en plus à l'instigation du
président la république monsieur khatami
voici le récit de ce qui se passe en ce
moment même sur la scène politique en
iran
le guide de la révolution l'ayatollah
khamenei successeur de khomeiny à ses
côtés le président khatami élu
massivement il ya deux ans à la surprise
générale grâce aux voix des jeunes et
des femmes entre ces deux hommes
la lutte est implacable l'un symbolise
l'iran traditionnel des religieux
l'autre une volonté d'ouvrir le pays a
une certaine modernité
vingt ans après la révolution iranienne
vie peut-être son thermidor ces jeunes
n'ont jamais connu un autre régime et ne
supporte plus les interdits imposés par
des religieux corrompu mais pour ceux
rétrograde les forces conservatrices au
sein de l'appareil d'état sont encore
extrêmement puissante
ce qu'on appelle par commodité de
langage les conservateurs détiennent
encore la haute main sur le parlement 2
sur les forces de répression
on l'a vu ces derniers jours trois sur
l'appareil judiciaire
ça c'est quand même trois poules très
important qu'ils maintiennent encore des
conservateurs qui ont tout essayé ces
derniers mois pour barrer la route aux
modernistes y compris en faisant
assassiner des opposants laïcs mais
cette lutte entre les deux clans se
déroule sur fond de crise économique 17%
l'inflation baisse du prix du pétrole
autant dire augmentation du coût de la
vie le régime est devenue insupportable
pour une majorité de la population qui
misent sur le président khatami pour
accélérer les réformes et gagner les
prochaines élections législatives en
février 2000 les manifestations
étudiantes peuvent l'aider dans cette
entreprise ou bien le gênait en cas de
débordement incontrôlé et de retour de
bâton de la part des conservateurs
c'est un retour spectaculaire sur la
scène diplomatique internationale pour
l'algérie le 35e sommet de
l'organisation de l'unité africaine ua
s'est ouvert ce matin à alger avec la
participation de plus de 40 chefs d'état
ou de gouvernement le président algérien
monsieur bouteflika succédera à la tête
de l'oeil au président du burkina faso
blaise campaoré
le sommet se tient sous très haute
surveillance avec des mesures de
sécurité très importantes
reportage eric meunier christian hutin
il tombe à point nommé ce 35e sommet de
l'organisation de l'unité africaine
abdelaziz bouteflika ne pouvait rêver
mieux pour illustrer le retour de
l'algérie sur la scène politique
internationale et son retour à lui chef
respecté de la diplomatie algérienne du
temps de sa splendeur
c'était il ya vingt ans et lg de rêver
jouer à nouveau les premiers rôles dans
le dialogue nord-sud
un autre retour celui de kadhafi
treize entourent le président libyen
espère obtenir un soutien à la levée
définitive des sanctions qui pèsent
contre son pays 43 chefs d'état ou de
gouvernement ou fait le voyage d'alger
un record parmi eux beaucoup dirige des
pays en guerre
il en sera question sans grand espoir de
solution pour le congolais sassou
n'guesso pour l'éthiopien mélès zenawi
ou l'erythréen essaye à sa fille work
ethiopie erythrée sans doute le conflit
le plus meurtrier aujourd'hui sur la
terre avec quelques raisons d'espérer en
revanche en sierra leone ou en
république démocratique du congo
laurent désiré kabila vient tout juste
de signer un accord avec les rebelles et
leurs parrains ouganda 01 pays n'est pas
encore en paix bien entendu aujourd'hui
dans le kca d'une des langues et a eu
deux attaques de france 3 sud opposition
congolaise à l'aube et il n'est pas
encore en parler nous participons
processus de paix partout où ces
processus se déclenche et l'oat ici
anakin d'occasion désigné président de
l'uia pour un nom abdelaziz bouteflika
sait qu'il devra d'abord convaincre les
différents protagonistes à s'asseoir et
à discuter les récents accords qu'il a
conclus avec certains mouvements
islamistes algériens auront valeur
d'exemple à suivre
fait rare le nouveau président entame
son mandat avec le soutien unanime de
ses homologues africains mais aussi les
européens et de washington
seul nelson mandela avait fait aussi
bien une référence
les participants à ce sommet d'alger
auront pris connaissance du rapport
mondial sur le développement humain des
nations unies alors sous cet intitulé
abstrait il y avait statistiques
particulièrement dérangeante concernant
les inégalités de richesse dans le monde
ainsi la fortune des trois hommes les
plus riches du monde dépasse les
ressources cumulé de tous les pays les
moins avancés et de leurs 600 millions
d'habitants quant aux pays les plus
riches
ils ont un quasi monopole du savoir et
de la communication explication cyrille
devaud les riches toujours plus riches
et un écart qui se creuse avec les pays
pauvres
aujourd'hui trois hommes les trois plus
fortunés de la planète sont plus riches
que 600 millions d'autres habitants les
35 pays les plus déshérités
parmi ces 3 bill gates le pdg de
microsoft et sa fortune personnelle de
550 milliards de francs comme lui ils
sont une poignée 200 personnes dont la
richesse dépasse les revenus de plus de
40 % de l'humanité soit 2 milliards 300
millions d'individus pour s'enrichir
aujourd'hui souligne le rapport des
nations unies
une seule solution maîtriser le savoir
contrôler le flux des connaissances
biotechnologies satellite informatique
réseaux de communication sont les
nouveaux outils de la mondialisation des
outils confisqué par le petit groupe des
29 pays les plus industrialisés à eux
seuls ils représentent 97% des brevets
trois quarts des lignes téléphoniques
neuf utilisateurs d'internet sur 10 un
ordinateur coûte en moyenne un mois de
salaire à un américain
huit années à un habitant du bangladesh
un succès technologique qui accroît les
inégalités entre les pays les plus
riches et les plus pauvres de la planète
l'écart de revenus a plus que doublé
depuis les années 60 la belgique un
nouveau gouvernement sous la direction
du libéral flamand guy verhofstadt c'est
une composition arc-en-ciel dirons-nous
avait des socialistes des écologistes
qui succède ainsi au gouvernement de
monsieur de à même le premier ministre a
prêté serment après avoir entendu le
mage lieu à nouveau promis sans prêter
serment devant le roi albert ii mercredi
pour le défilé du 14 juillet à paris la
nouveauté sera marocaine avec 550
fantassins de la garde royale sur les
champs elysées et puis aux côtés du
président chirac il y aura le roi hassan
2 celui ci est arrivé cet après midi à
paris ils étaient accueillis par le
président de la république c'est
l'inquiétude pour la station mir et ses
occupants l'équipage est composé des
cosmonautes russes afanassiev et à
vf ainsi que du français jean pierre
haigneré mire doit être impérativement
ravitailler mais la fusée qui doit lui
apporter nécessaires dont le lancement
est prévu mercredi
depuis baïkonour au kazakhstan est pour
l'instant bloquée sur son pas de tir
pour des raisons administratives et
politiques commentaires patrice pollet à
baïkonour
personne ne sait encore si cette fusée
avec à son bord le vaisseau progress
décollera mercredi 14 juillet en
direction de 1000 il le faudrait
pourtant garnir avec trois hommes à bord
dont le français jean pierre haigneré
attendent d'être ravitaillée par cette
fusée précisément mais depuis une
semaine les casaques refuse de lancer
quelques engins que ce soit le
contentieux remonte à la semaine
dernière lorsqu'une fusée proton
s'écrase après quelques minutes de vol
larguant généreusement sur son passage
une pluie de ferraille et de carburant
toxique
la protestation des casaques est
immédiate de plus il rappelle aux russes
les impayés de la location du site de
baïkonour 150 millions de dollars par an
payés depuis 95 depuis une semaine
depuis le début des négociations entre
russes et kazakhs
l'ambiance se fait lourde dormir sans
eau sans nourriture
le retour du dernier équipage de la
station prévue phare août devrait être
avancée
on peut comprendre ce soir l'inquiétude
des derniers habitants de l'espace à
baïkonour cependant contre vents et
marées les russes continuent la
préparation du lancement pour mercredi
pour le cas où les casaques donneraient
leur feu vert
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'exemple des
grands travaux reliés la banlieue est de
paris au centre de la capitale a
nécessité sept années de chantier la
ligne eole est cher très cher 8
milliards de francs
elle a causé beaucoup de soucis aux
riverains et entraîner les conditions de
travail souvent très périlleuse pour les
houris ce matin le premier ministre
inaugurait cette cinquième ligne de rer
parisien reportage hugo plagnard et
patrick descheemaecker sept ans de
travaux pour passer du virtuel au réel
eole la toute nouvelle ligne de rer
s'élance vers la banlieue ouest de paris
cent soixante dix mille voyageurs
emprunteront chaque jour ces rames
dernier cri qui peuvent transporter
chacune deux mille cinq cents passagers
dans les entrailles de la capitale et
hall ce sont quatre kilomètres
supplémentaires de tunnels et surtout
deux gars parmi les plus grandes
d'europe
mais ce beau projet plusieurs centaines
de parisiens n'ont essuyé les plâtres
parmi eux alain d'haguenau quand les
travaux ont commencé les murs de son
appartement se sont fissurés les experts
ont désigné la sncf comme responsable
nous avons eu à peu près quatre
expertises avec une vingtaine de
personnes ils ont reconnu donc
effectivement la responsabilité et
pourtant aucune indemnisation rien rien
n'est venu
des propositions ont été faites à des
propriétaires des propriétaires qui les
ont pour certains accepter d'autres
propriétaires les ont contesté par que
c'est leur droit de les contester devant
devant les tribunaux outre la
mobilisation des riverains les
bâtisseurs des vols ont été confrontés à
de nombreux problèmes techniques de ces
galeries où les conditions de travail
étaient des plus difficiles il a fallu
extraire une masse de gravats comparable
à celle de la pyramide de khéops et
assécher une vaste poche d'eau pour
construire la gare haussmann
résultat le chantier a coûté plus de 8
milliards de francs contre 6 milliards
prévus tout cela à cause de la sncf
selon le président de la région
manifestement il ya eu à la fois au
niveau de la de la préparation du
chantier de la conduite du chantier
et puis de la vérification des désordres
donner aux entreprises un laxisme est
une espèce de virer de laisser alec
absolument inadmissible une dérive
financière dont les pouvoirs publics
entendent tirer les leçons estimé au
minimum à 1 milliard et demi de francs
le prolongement d'eole vers l'ouest
parisien risque de ne pas voir le jour
en ile-de-france la priorité sera donnée
aux transports publics de surface comme
ici le tramway val de seine utilisé
depuis 1997 pour relier la défense à
issy les moulineaux un choix plus
économique
1 km de tunnels peut coûter jusqu'à 1
milliard de francs c'est six fois moins
cher pour la même distance en tramway
voilà et cette ligne eole sera gratuite
le 14 juillet si vous voulez faire sa
connaissance
onze ans dans l'enceinte de l'aéroport
de roissy 11 ans de la vie d'un
apatrides iranien apatrides malgré lui
monsieur alfred comme on avait pris
l'habitude de le nommer monsieur alpha
vient d'obtenir un statut de réfugié
politique en belgique il paraît qu'on
avait égaré ses papiers il est
maintenant théoriquement libres de
partir mais pour où et pourquoi
reportage patrick fandio jean louis goût
serre ce pourrait être un passager qui
attend son vol dans la sérénité mais
meyrannes karine naceri ne prendra pas
de vol aujourd'hui même si l'on a de
nouveau le droit depuis quelques jours
la belgique vient de lui confirmer son
statut de réfugié politique ce qu'ils
réclamaient depuis 11 ans une éternité
passé dans cette zone de transit de
roissy sa situation régularisée
monsieur alfred comme il aime se faire
appeler n'a pourtant pas plier bagage
je ne vais aller nulle part
quand je vais continuer à rester
pourquoi vous avez vos papiers
oui j'ai ma carte maintenant mais il me
manque encore un titre de transport
en fait si cet iranien de 54 ans a
retrouvé son statut de réfugié il n'a
toujours pas de titre de transport
un document qui lui servirait de
passeport et lui permettrait de voyager
ce sera sa prochaine démarches
administratives une de plus dans cette
absurde imbroglio juridico diplomatique
qui dure depuis qu'alfred a perdu toutes
ses pièces d'identité en 1988 cet autre
réfugié iranien n'a manqué aucun épisode
de cette saga
et chaque fois que j'y passe et je
visite et je demandais comment ça va
comment allez vous le savez c'est
important pour quelqu'un qui est au
moins de vue plus vieux pour alfred le
quotidien n'a pas changé ce matin jus
d'orange et café au petit déjeuner servi
par des vendeuses qui vont peut-être
bientôt perdre un client fidèle
là je suis content pour lui alors
on n'y va pas sa définition à la les
comprend quand même alfred s'est
installé dans une zone publique de
l'aéroport il n'est pas en infraction
regard de la loi
personne ne peut l'obliger à partir à
supposer qu'il en est encore en vie une
deuxième belle et bonne année pour les
résultats du baccalauréat toutes
disciplines confondues il y avait
exactement 621 1405 candidats cette
année et les reçus sont au nombre de 4
186 1575
alors bravo pour eux et puis il faut
saluer les académies de rennes grenoble
et nantes en tête de la réussite
reportage stéphane haumant ligue dachau
fun 78,3 % de réussite au bac 99 n'égale
pas le record historique de l'an dernier
mais les lycéens réalise tout de même la
deuxième meilleure statistique depuis 30
ans avec 4600 candidats de plus qu'en 98
ils sont pourtant mille 500 bacheliers
de moins 480 6575 laura exactement soit
61,1 % de la classe d'âge sur 100
candidats 53 ont décroché un bac général
30 un bac technologique et 17 un bac
professionnel c'est plus que d'habitude
le bac pro à la cote
au palmarès des académies reine arrive
en tête comme l'an dernier avec le même
score 83 9% de réussite au bac général
2e grenoble avec 83 points 8 % en légère
hausse
troisième 90 à 82 7% derrière plusieurs
académies passe la barre symbolique des
80 % besançon clermont lyon strasbourg
toulouse et versailles
en queue de liste arrive créteil bon
dernier avec seulement 70 3 % de
réussite de nouveaux cas de vache folle
dans les départements de l'aube et celui
des côtes d'armor sur un cheptel de 21
millions de têtes on a répertorié depuis
le début de l'année 14 cas
d'encéphalopathie spongiforme bovine en
france dans les calanques de marseille
la pollution vient de l'absence de
l'enlèvement des ordures ménagères
depuis trois semaines depuis trois
semaines elles ne sont pas remplacés en
effet et jusqu'à présent c'était le
personnel de l'office national des
forêts qui faisait le nécessaire mais
faute d'argent
plus personne ne veut s'en occuper
reportage jacques cardoze
sauvage pur les calanques marseillaise
bénéficie d'une réputation presque
unique au monde
mais ces jours ci les amateurs d'image
de rêve risque de respirer de travers au
vu de ceux ci voilà le résultat de la
dernière histoire marseillaise trois
semaines d'ordures entre mer et roche
drôle de paradis sauf surprise
nationalement mais choqué avant toute
chose parce que c'est
c'est lamentable la première fois c'est
lamentable
il y en a ici il y en a 1 l'autre côté
sur le chemin je pense d'ailleurs que
c'est pas forcément la faute aux gens
parce que salaires des poubelles
publiques public est habituellement
gérées par l'office national des forêts
mais cet organisme d'état a épuisé tous
ses crédits cette année et préfère
mobilisé son personnel à la prévention
incendie
on a pu poursuivre l'intervention
jusqu'à la fin du printemps mais où les
villas saison estivale volumes étant
trop importants j'ai pu mobiliser les
personnels qui était affecté toute façon
à d'autres tâches notamment aux
patrouilles aux patrouilles incendie une
histoire marseillaise qui se transforme
en bagarre politicienne les
collectivités locales se renvoient la
balle mais leurs représentants se montre
scandalisé moi je trouve que de faire la
politique à ce degré là c'est le ramener
au degré de ce que l'on voit c'est
scandaleux et ignobles essayer de
pénaliser en environnement que tout le
monde veut défendre à part des mesures
politicienne qui n'ont pas avoir lieu
dans ce magnifique massif difficile de
savoir à qui en incombe la
responsabilité mais pendant ce temps les
bateliers eux continuent de déverser des
dizaines de touristes sans les avertir
qu'ils sont parfois au milieu d'un site
protégé du sport cycliste une journée de
repos aujourd'hui pour les coureurs du
tour de france ils sont encore 174 en
course au cours du transfert via
l'aéroport de genève avait voir une
poignée de main sereine
discrète mais symbolique entre richard
virenque et jean marie leblanc directeur
général du tour qui n'avaient pourtant
pas souhaité la présence du coureur de
l'équipe paul qui demain 9e étape
c'est entre le grand bornand et
sestrières et c'est sur france
télévisions pour la coupe du monde de
rugby 30 joueurs ont été sélectionnés en
équipe de france alors voici poste par
poste les sélectionnés on retiendra
l'absence de philippe benetton jean luc
sadourny sylvain marconnet et puis les
présences plutôt surprise de 10
hilmar lui peter de villiers qui est
originaire d'afrique du sud et cédric
desbrosses voilà 12 juillet ça vous dit
forcément quelque chose il ya un an une
france en bleu blanc rouge se mettait à
chanter en l'honneur des vainqueurs de
la coupe du monde de football bonne
anniversaire donc à l'équipe d'aimé
jacquet un an après pour le plaisir nous
vous offrons ce soir quelques-uns des
bus français de ce mondial 98 avec les
commentaires de christian tortora
il est désert qui sont encore dans
toutes les mémoires
l'histoire débute un soir de juin 98
contre l'afrique du sud
il était une fois un groupe parti à la
recherche du but en or face au paraguay
sur leur route ils rencontrent les pires
difficultés devant l'italie
m
ensuite il évite le pire face à la
croatie
il était une fois l'équipe de france
championne du monde de football
ça
dans toutes les villes dans tous les
coeurs et les flottes ce parfum du
bonheur la france fière de son équipe
fier de ses couleurs
c'était le 12 juillet dernier c'était il
ya un an déjà et du soleil dans les
revers il ya de la joie
bah voilà puis vous avez revu le match
la finale de la coupe du monde il ya
quelques instants c'était sur france 2
alors les bleus ont été largement
célébrés ils ont beaucoup parlé on les a
vus récemment chez michel drucker sur
france 2 dans un tapis rouge alors nous
avons voulu tourner notre attention vers
celui qui fut le grand perdant le brésil
et principalement ronaldo s'était lui
qu'on attendait il devait faire un
triomphe au stade de france dans
quelques instants vous entendrez ronaldo
un an après celui qu'on appelle le
meilleur joueur du monde semble
retrouver la plus grande part de son
talent et donc de renouer avec la
réussite
ronaldo c'est presque un mythe dans le
football présentation christophe
duchiron il ya chez ce jeune homme riche
et célèbre
quelque chose qui tient du mouton
à l'image de leonardo dicaprio cinéma
ronaldo fait partie de ces gens que le
destin a choisi exceptionnellement
robuste incroyablement véloce
puissamment technique pour parler de
ronaldo il n'est pas rare d'employer le
complément d'objet direct ni d'avoir la
référence historique
avec pelé le brésil a donné un roi au
football descendant du roi
ronaldo n'est encore qu'un prince d'ubs
à londres
la différence du roi pelé le petit
prince n'est pas né dans une de ces
favelas du brésil mais dans un quartier
modeste et populaire de rio de janeiro
plus familier des terrains vagues que
des bancs de l'école
celui que l'on surnomme d'adado ne va
pas tarder à sortir durant quinze ans
plus tard sans diplôme il a fait fortune
et aujourd'hui on visite la rue de son
enfance et le monde entier connaît le
numéro de sa maison de jeunesse
c'est en europe qu'il deviendra le
meilleur joueur du monde aux pays-bas
puis à barcelone ronaldo fait valser les
défenseurs et les finances
en 1997 l'inter de milan langage pour la
somme record de 180 millions de francs
il en évoque un salaire mensuel qui
dépasse les 2 millions ajoutés les
contrats avec les sponsors c'est le
salaire de la sueur
avec le maillot du brésil sa cote grand
vit au rythme des buts marqués ballon
d'or joueur en or ronaldo croit en dieu
et en son destin
toutes les portes s'ouvrent à lui reçu
par le pape jean paul ii en compagnie de
sa mère c'était l'an dernier le 12
juillet 1998 marque comme un coup
d'arrêt il avait fait de la coupe du
monde
l'objet de son désir mais que vois quil
ce 12 juillet des français tout sourire
qui s'étreignent de bonheur visage fermé
des mauvais jours
l'après-midi de la finale ronaldo est
victime d'un malaise pris de convulsions
dont on ne connaît toujours pas les
causes
après un examen de contrôle il décidera
de jouer quelques minutes seulement
avant le début de la rencontre
au cours du match une occasion une seule
et c'est raté
le dimanche 12 juillet ronaldo perd sa
finale de coupe du monde un vendredi 13
ça n'aurait pas été pire
juillet 99 depuis quelques jours ronaldo
dispute la coupe america avec l'équipe
du brésil
et s'il a longtemps été blessé au genou
cette saison avec l'inter de milan
ces derniers temps il a retrouvé la
santé et le chemin des filets
non après ce 12 juillet ronaldo n'est
peut-être plus tout à fait ce qu'il
était mais il reste encore un mythe une
de ses icônes qui font rêver les joueurs
de plages de rio
luis nazario de lima dit ronaldo il a
presque 23 ans et toute la vie devant
lui
alors vos silicone car en exclusivité
pour france 2 christophe tortora nous
avons sollicité ronaldo depuis son stage
d'entraînement actuellement au brésil où
il se trouve avec l'équipe brésilienne
il ya quelques jours nous avons
enregistré cet entretien première
question à ronaldo quels souvenirs
gardes at il de cette coupe du monde et
de la défaite brésilienne
je garde un triste souvenir de ce
mondial
même si nous avons joué un grand
championnat malheureusement nous sommes
arrivés en finale avec plusieurs
problèmes et nous avons perdu cette
finale la sélection brésilienne est
d'ailleurs jamais véritablement rentrer
dans ce match on n'a pas bien joué la
finale
alors pour moi cette coupe du monde
reste un grand souvenir
mais un triste souvenir est-ce que
c'était logique cette victoire de la
france face au brésil qui était pourtant
le grand favori
non sans bien sûr enlever les mérites de
la france le brésil en finale n'a pas eu
de véritable action de but
malheureusement nous n'étions pas
concentrés comme nous aurions dû l'être
bien sûr la france a joué un grand match
et a eu beaucoup de mérite dans l'équipe
il y a de grands joueurs est
pratiquement à partir du premier but de
zidane l'issue du match était connue des
fonds est-ce que vous même ronaldo vous
aviez tous vos moyens pour jouer cette
finale
j'ai eu un malaise
l'après midi avant la finale ce qui bien
sûr a perturbé ma concentration
je suis allé dans une clinique à paris
pour effectuer des examens mais les
examens ont révélé que j'étais en pleine
forme pour jouer j'en ai parlé avec le
médecin de l'équipe avec l'entraîneur je
leur ai dit que je voulais jouer cette
partie est donnée bien sûr le meilleur
de moi même
malheureusement cela n'a pas été
suffisant pour que l'on gagne le match
mais un an après ce que vous ne
regrettez pas d'avoir joué sans la
plénitude de vos moyens justement
ah non pas du tout pour taire je ne
regrette absolument pas ce que j'ai fait
j'aurai un regret si je n'avais pas joué
ce match si on avait perdu de toute
façon j'aurais un énorme regret mais
avez vous pris la décision de jouer seul
ou est ce que ce sont vos sponsors
votre entraîneur c'est un entourage qui
vous a demandé de jouer ou est ce que
c'est vous même qui avait demandé à
jouer
indécent fonds convoque non la décision
de jouer a été une décision d'ensemble
prise en accord avec la commission
technique de la sélection
bien sûr j'ai eu le dernier mot c'est
moi qui ai dit que j'avais la condition
physique pour jouer le match
les sponsors n'avaient pas la
possibilité d'accéder au risque
r à ce moment là avec l'aval du médecin
j'ai donc décidé de jouer quel est le
plus qu'apporte le brésil au football
dans le monde d'après vous le brésil a
toujours une très grande joie quand ils
jouent au football
on montre à chaque fois des choses
nouvelles nous quand on joue quel que
soit l'endroit dans le monde on ne voit
pas une équipe jouer avec autant de
techniques d'habilité et de joie que
l'équipe brésilienne
alors pour conclure cet entretien je
sais que vous connaissez quelques mots
de français ce que vous pourriez me les
répéter bien je connais très peu de mots
en français mais je vais seigner bongeot
humans
et il ya aussi une chanson que djorkaeff
chanter pour se moquer d'eux et niasse
et de moi même
après la victoire de la france en coupe
du monde contre la sélection brésilienne
merci beaucoup ronaldo merci nous avons
accordé cet entretien je vous souhaite
un bel avenir de footballeur merci voilà
il ça marche bien pour lui actuellement
donc puisque le brésil est qualifié pour
les demi finales de la copa la coupe
d'amérique du sud
nous allons maintenant on retrouvait
pour cette dernière page du journal les
chorégies d'orange c'est chorégies se
sont ouvertes samedi dernier avec la
traviata de verdi
d'autres oeuvres d'autres concerts bien
sûr sont programmées avec notamment en
soliste le pianiste russe evgeny kissin
ce soir c'est ce que l'on appelle un
prodige
on dit même qu'ils fille pleurait
karajan reportage michel pontet et jean
lemelin
parce qu'à ce niveau de compréhension de
la musique en est forcément seul f gagne
ici ne l'est plus que tout autre
à 27 ans il a déjà tout chemin et semble
avoir aussi tout 110 mais plus
intensément que le reste des humains et
l'on ne peut s'empêcher de chercher où
se cacherait en lui l'explication
visible d'un prodige qui se joue de
toutes les difficultés du clavier est
dans ses mains est-ce dans ses yeux qui
semblait monter sans cesse vers la
solitude d'un piano de concert au fond
d'une fosse et qui l'attend soir après
soir
ce jour-là il est arrivé dans le théâtre
encore dr trois heures avant la
répétition
pas un seul instant une assemblée nous
voir peut être parce qu'il lui fallait
encore dompté le four face à lui
on entend mener oui certes nous les
musiciens avant de la chance mais je
crois aussi que tous ceux qui après ça
me wade le pouvoir et la beauté
n'arrivait saison aussi peut être
quelque part de mieux de la chance
une heure plus tard alors que
l'orchestré finissait de s'installer
bruyamment son prêter attention à lui
kiss-in était déjà lui dans le pur
bonheur de la musique encore seul un
instant certes mais se préparant à nous
offrir
comme mon cadeau le son splendide de
cette solitude
voilà c'est chorégies d'orange et c'est
ce soir evgeny kissin une dernière
soirée un dernier spectacle en france
pour evgeny kissin ce soir à orange
voilà nous arrivons à la fin de ce
journal je vous rappelle les
informations concernant la situation en
iran où les troubles s'accroissent les
manifestations étudiantes se sont
multipliées ces dernières heures la
population proteste contre les violences
policières et la mort un étudiant à
tabriz et les manifestants réclament et
demandent instamment des réformes
démocratiques au président attali dans
quelques secondes la météo avec nathalie
rihouet et puis après je sans frontières
a présenté par nelson monfort et
fabienne égal vous retrouverez 22h45 au
coeur des bleus
c'est le fameux documentaire de mireille
dumas et dominique colonna sur les
champions du monde
c'était il ya un an tout juste à 1h10 le
journal de la nuit vous sera présentée
par laurence ostolaza à 13 heures demain
vous retrouverez carole gaessler rachid
arhab et puis à demain 20 heures dont
soir merci
oh